the world of philanthropy and charities
is in its infancy it's sort of like an
infant industry certainly it's been
around for a while and there are some
very prominent philanthropists who have
been known for for a century or more but
I think what's important to understand
is as the industry develops they're
going to be good players and bad players
and so in terms of charities what we are
trying to explain to people is that yes
giving is great it's good for your
health or many reasons why you should be
participating in trying to change the
world around you at the same time you
also have to be careful there are some
cherries that are much better at it
there are some cherries that are scams
and you have to be careful and you know
sometimes there are some real rotten
apples but you can't let the rotten
apples spoil the entire industry the
world of charities is extremely broad
and I think that what's really important
is to sort of know what your goals are
what you want to do for us we were
saying okay I think that a lot of
charities should target the needy people
who need it certainly some of the
nonprofit's put a lot of effort into
like a church for instance has to keep
up the church and make it look very nice
for the public and that's very all well
and good and they need to renovate the
outside of the building that's that's
all well and good especially when it
comes to museums when it comes to things
like the Sistine Chapel of course but
when it really comes to trying to help
the poor I mean that is what the essence
is of charities to help people who are
underprivileged a surprising amount of
philanthropic dollars don't go to the
needy even in higher ed there was a
study done by the Indiana Center for
philanthropy that found that only a
small portion less than fifty percent
far less and fifty percent actually
ended up helping poor students who
couldn't afford to go to college now
it's not by intent it's just that we
need to become more efficient this
industry needs to become a lot more
efficient and needs to target much more
clearly the needy altruism actually is a
very interesting phenomenon so we
actually
think that when we give we're losing
something we're giving some of our money
our time or resources to someone else it
turns out when that neuro scientists who
have studied altruism they found some
interesting results in a survey that
looked at many different people they
discovered that when you give you
stimulate a part of the brain it lights
up this part of the brain and that part
is very similar to the same part of the
brain that is stimulated when you engage
in pleasures like eating candy or eating
ice cream falling in love it's the same
area and in half of research subjects it
turns out that they're feeling of
pleasure was more intense when they gave
then when they received so being
altruistic makes you feel better makes
you feel happier it turns out that
volunteering is very good for your
health and we all want to live longer
but we all face a risk of mortality if
you go to church regularly and you it's
a very social environment you're really
trying to be compassionate you learn
compassion that actually reduces your
risk of mortality by twenty nine percent
research shows if you exercise four
times a week maybe more that reduces
your risk of mortality by thirty percent
if you volunteer for two or more
organizations that decreases your risk
of mortality by a whopping forty four
percent so volunteering being
compassionate helping other people it's
good for your health so if you want to
volunteer what we've done in in a path
appears is we have a list of dozens of
organizations but what's most important
is for you to find something that you're
interested in it doesn't work to sort of
say okay everybody's volunteering for
the Red Cross let me help to you really
want to think about what it is that you
care about because you have a different
background from your friends or from
other people you want to find out what
moves you and you might be able to match
your skill set as well if you think that
you're
computer scientists you certainly could
donate some of your computer science
skills but I do think that if you could
find a group of friends who have similar
interests you can do it together you can
talk about it it becomes a social thing
we really could learn a lot from the way
mega churches operate they make giving a
social event a joyous event on a regular
basis and so we really do think that if
you can make it something part of your
life with some friends you'll enjoy it
even much more we think that in a path
appears is really important for people
to understand to two basic things one is
that there are many ways to address
inequality it's a disturbing trend even
Obama said it was going to be the
challenge of our time and it's important
to really try and see how we can address
that and we can we can address that by
spreading opportunity throughout the
country and the most efficient way of
doing that is by intervening early
through early childhood education we're
talking about age 1 2 3 even before the
official public school system kicks in
because your brain the brain is forming
much more rapidly during those early
years in the first 1000 days so if you
can capture that window and milk it for
what it is you'll be far more effective
in altering a life path particularly if
it's a child born to parents on welfare
or impoverished parents you really want
to change that life path and you can
intervene later of course but it is much
harder and much more expensive and the
second thing is that it really is
important for everybody to get involved
as we you know I've talked about the
health benefits it really not only helps
move and change the world around you but
it also helps you as well and the family
and friends around you
you